[Applause]  west virginia fighting short season one  of the whistle don't get it  outside this is who they want to shoot  it they need it they got it  how about oh samoan again yup mcbride  splits  comes flying through put a pass what do  you  are think matthews why not absolutely  the mountaineers get something here  quickly  10 seconds to go big bride to matthews  oh saboyeon gets in there with 4.3  seconds at a timeout  this one takes care of business this  would end it yeah that's it  for two seconds mcbride he walked he did  he did walk i'll tell you what jim  bayheims won a lot of games  did you see them jump trap that  i mean goodness we talked about vacating  everybody  but look at this jump trap and this is a  great great  college player this is mcbride and  goodness how sweet it is for syracuse  bill  never count them or him out  two buddies at the hip court chatting  away